John there's an illegal shipment of RPGs
headed your way I'm on it
Diana what say you like Italian right
now make some time all but you're in the
middle of a high-speed chase I haven't
asked you there will be two types of
criminals left and starting to see it
once we put away the ones that are
running scared you keep this up there
won't be any criminals that fit me to
rust
you have failed this city how are you
did you wish I was still a detective
I've got to go you got a hot date or
something
don't look so surprised Adam been gone
Batman
something's never died you for example
Ray Palmer parked on your roof I hope
that's okay
yes validate right
there are still a few things that you
don't know about me I never said I
didn't know how to use a gun
hey youtubers it's Charlie it's a whole
bunch of arrows stuff happening today
new trailer and they just announced Ra's
al Ghul so I'm gonna start with my
breakdown of all the new trailer footage
and then I'll talk about Ra's al Ghul so
the trailer they're calling the
high-speed chase promo it was really all
about showing off the secondary
characters like Malcolm Merlyn the Ray
Palmer vertigo some of the footage was
repeated from the earlier trailer so I'm
just gonna focus on the new stuff so
starting off with said high-speed chase
obviously just highlight in fact that
team arrow has been kicking butt since
the season 2 finale the funny part here
is that you could see Felicity is
working inside a tech village anyone who
watched Chuck probably got like a buy
more vibe from this if you didn't watch
that Brandon rouse character played an
evil secret agent so you should watch
that it's all on Netflix it's a lot of
fun really the funny thought is Felicity
being the Chuck character you know
Zachary Levi is character who actually
moderated like Stephen amell's and all
those other awesome interviews from
Comic Con the other side of this though
is why is she working inside the tech
village if you remember at the end of
last season they basically had the arrow
cave destroyed and even though it looks
like they rebuilt it they basically
still have no money she's probably just
working there as a day job and hijacking
the equipment to help Oliver with the
extracurricular activities and then
there's all the olicity stuff that's
going on here to obviously him asking
her about what kind of food she wants on
their date since the first episode the
premiere is whenever this big date is
supposed to go down I'm guessing all
these scenes from this trailer are from
that first episode they haven't been
dating all summer or anything like that
we saw the scene where he actually asked
her out for the first time in the first
season three trailer so this scene pleye
just comes after that scene it also
makes me wonder what Felicity's favorite
food is besides pizza I feel like every
characters favorite food is pizza
the Diggle voiceover just explains
they've been kicking ass and reducing
crime levels to near zero the title of
the premiere is the calm which obviously
means a lot of things both the crime is
almost gone and the calm before the
storm for example - there was this time
in the comic books whenever Batman
basically went away and you saw this
like 90% rise in the level of crime so
it gives you an idea of what having a
superhero does to the crime level inside
a city but speaking of storm moving
along we have a shot of Peter Stormare
as
to go it shows a finished visual effect
of what he's gonna look like when people
are tripping on the vertigo drug and a
lot of people were confused and thought
that he might have special powers
he doesn't have special powers this is
just like Oliver or whoever's looking at
him hallucinating I do like that they
updated the vertigo look and just made
it look way crazier I also kind of
wonder if they work the title of the
episode after casting Peter Stormare so
they could say the calm before the storm
err usually things don't happen that way
it's probably just a coincidence but I
like thinking of the idea that there's
someone in the writers room just
laughing to himself so then following up
super bad guy was super good guy Ray
Palmer for those that haven't read the
comics Ray Palmer is the atom another
superhero so we know he's gonna be good
and he'll join team arrow at some point
this season but when we first meet him
he'll be yanking Oliver's company and
possibly you linking felicity
so he and Oliver are gonna have this
really awkward relationship that'll be
kind of funny at least until they have
their bro moment where they bond their
borough mint I'm sure this plugin has
something to do with Merlyn or Peter
Stormare of the villains this season his
scene is super quick but one of the big
things that shows us is how funny season
3 is gonna be Stephen Amell for example
said that he smiled more in the first
episode than he had in all of seasons 1
& 2 combined
he said that whenever they were actually
filming those scenes where he smiles a
lot that he had to do it a couple times
just because he wasn't used to smiling
on camera like it was a new thing to him
it just gives you an idea for how
serious Oliver used to be - how much
lighter he's gonna be this season the
whole tone of the show in general is
lightening up and I think it's gonna
make it a lot more fun to watch so this
is this big thing going on at DC's film
unit it's kind of a rumor kind of not of
a rumor that they do not like jokes like
they want the film characters like
Batman vs Superman characters to be
super serious super dark but that is not
the case thankfully in the TV universe I
just feel like it would make it so much
harder to watch if none of the
characters ever got to be funny and
adding Brandon Rath is a foil for
Stephen Amell gives us so many
opportunities for Oliver to react to
things usually it's been Felicity
reacting to him being crazy intense but
now the power dynamic has shifted a
little so Ray Palmer is like a tech
giant who owns his company who buys a
majority stake in Queen industries so
he's kind of like Oliver's new boss
season it's not like in the toxic sexual
kind of way that Summer Glau is his boss
last year
I'm sure tumblr just gonna have some fun
with that Oliver Summer Glau Brandon
Ralph gifts that stuff though everybody
watch out for that because it's coming
but moving along we have the new
attitude tag that basically is mostly
talking about the secondary characters
stepping up I keep shipping Laurel it's
kind of like this Kate Spencer Manhunter
analog this year
that's not exactly what the show is
doing with her she's just gonna start
taking a page from Oliver's book and
getting more hands-on with the Justice
you know just getting more punchy really
of course is full-on sidekick he was
kind of a rage zombie for most of last
season so I'm really happy that he
actually gets some more interesting
stuff to do so then we move on to Thea
and training as much as I wanted to
become Artemis I feel like the show's
gonna be more ambiguous about her
identity she'll just be like a more
punchy version of Thea just like Laurel
is getting more punchy no idea where
this training is happening though but
I'm guessing it's not Starling city I'm
really happy for Willa Holland though
one of the things I'm most looking
forward to is her kicking Roy's butt a
little they're not gonna be enemies all
season or anything like that but they
will have an antagonistic relationship
but there's always gonna be that amount
of sexual tension between them Merlyn
finally appears - I was kind of bummed
that he hadn't been in any of the
earlier trailers but now it seems like
he's hijacking a truck in this shop we
still don't know a lot about what his
arc is gonna be in season 3 or how it's
gonna relate to team arrow
I was thinking Merlyn is like this
neutral third party you know he could
work with you or work against you as it
suits him like if he sees something that
you can help him get he will totally
work with you I'm really hoping that he
teams up with Oliver against Ra's al
Ghul before the finale there will be
plenty of them beating the crap at each
other before that though so then we get
to that olicity Dateline where it's like
you don't know everything about me
that's basically just gonna set off the
Hong Kong flashbacks the confusing part
of the trailer is here actually where
Oliver and Roy aren't in costume and
they're fighting these military dudes
either this happens on an undercover
mission or it's part of the big
overarching plot like these military
people might be mercenaries working for
count vertigo and these shipping
containers might be his drugs
but yes you totally did see that right
Oliver did shoot and kill those people
it's a big left turn from his not
killing people thing in season 2 and
actually yes looking at Roy's quiver on
his back here makes me think that this
was an undercover
so that's basically it for the new
footage but you know reminder on the
premiere October 8th at 8 p.m. Eastern
Time on the CW if you're watching it in
an international country it's basically
gonna be the same delay window between
the premiere in the US and where
premiers in your country is it was last
season so if you had to wait a week to
get it before like you're in the UK and
you had to wait like one or a couple
weeks it'll basically be the same thing
and don't forget the flash is also
premiering Tuesday the 7th I will be
doing videos for all the DC TV shows
there are four of them including Gotham
the flash arrow and Constantine I
haven't quite got my October schedule
worked out because all those shows are
premiering in October but be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll probably do a separate video just
for what my fall schedule is gonna be
and post that once I figure it out but
now on to Ra's al Ghul casting this is
the other big bomb they dropped today's
Stephen Amell actually made the
announcement on his Twitter account
they picked Matt Nabal he's another
Aussie which I actually think is a
pretty awesome coincidence given that
Manu Bennett was the big bad last year I
mean technically Manu is a Kiwi he's
from New Zealand but you get the idea
just imagine this meta thing going on
where Slade is secretly related to Ra's
al Ghul just because they bear up
passing resemblance to each other in
real life that's not true obviously in
the comics but it's just another point
of conversation for tumblr to pick up
and run with even if you haven't seen a
lot of Matt enabled before you might
remember him from the last Riddick movie
like the third Riddick movie here's an
interview with him they just kind of
gives you an idea for what he sounds
like and has been looking for Riddick
for quite some time you know we'd
imagine and like I said he's after some
answers from Riddick
regarding his own son and and what
happened to him so he's not too
concerned about the bounty or the money
that's been put on his head as far as
collecting it he's more interested in
getting the answers he requires that to
I guess have some sort of rest over he's
probably gonna adjust his Beach patterns
just a little bit to suit Ra's al Ghul
but you get the idea though I cannot
wait to see him unleash on Starling lots
of questions as to why he's coming to
town though you know although Malcolm
Merlyn Black Canary vertigo they could
all be possible reasons but I'm actually
really interested to see is how Brandon
Ralph's character how Ray Palmer is
gonna overlap with Ra's al Ghul in the
comics the atom doesn't interact with
Ra's al Ghul
but obviously arrow does a really good
job of tying together all the different
big character plots we can talk a little
bit more about how the character arts
might overlap before the finale just
because there's a lot of different
directions they could go with it since
we're within like the four week window
of the premiere please let me know what
kind of arrow flash Constantine etc up
bonus videos you want to see me do
whenever we get to the week before that
premiere I'll be doing extra bonus
videos on top of everything just to help
everyone get ready for all these new
shows because it's gonna be a lot of fun
it's gonna be a fun season like I said
I'm still trying to figure out what my
schedules gonna be you know ideally I'll
just I'll post my videos for each show
like right after they air but I'll be
sure to post a separate video as soon as
I'm done figuring it out but right now
click here to learn all about Ra's al
Ghul and click here to get my villains
power ranking for season 3 thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives